tout est propre tout est beau tout est
prêtre est opéré mais malheureusement
avec la situation actuelle
et pas question de le trouver un
locataire bernard ragueneau a fondé le
top 10 il ya 50 ans il y avait mille
personnes ici tous les jours
évidemment les années 80-90 même 2000 on
était très florissant
[Musique]
il a loué à l'automne 2010 8 mai le
nouvel exploitant a fait faillite et
l'immeuble de trois étages est inoccupé
depuis plus d'un an
malheureusement les frais fixes sont
restés les frais fixes certaines sommes
quand vous savez taxes municipales qui
sont déjà exorbitants à montréal on
parle de avis pour les 6 420 misola les
assurances et un autre 150000 apprécié
le chauffeur tout ça il faut le garder
parce que la prochaine fois montréal
vivaient déjà le problème de locaux
vacants et c'est encore pire avec la
pandémie
le danger son perte de vitalité
commerciale auto un effet d'entraînement
négatif si mes voisins ont fermé et
c'est dur pour moi il est possible que
je me pose la question pourquoi je reste
ouvert et six mois mais voisins ont
fermé il n'attire plus de clientèle qui
va venir par contagion positive dans mon
commerce aider les petits propriétaires
pourraient entre autres passer par une
réduction des taxes municipales le taux
non résidentiels et résidentiel à
montréal et quatre pour un fort et du
verso pour donner une marge de manoeuvre
aux propriétaires puis le fardeau
administratif et réglementaire qui peut
empêcher certaines pme de pouvoir
excéder un local qui répondent à leurs
besoins
parce que ça rentre pas dans les
critères de la réglementation qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez vous pas vous
regarder sa lettre moi je l'appelle
vraiment débarrasser et puis c'est tout
le propriétaire du tos des amis sa
bâtisse à vendre pour 10 millions soit
la valeur de l'évaluation municipale
ils veulent tous achetés mais ils sont
par jean solution ce que quelqu'un
vienne ici une bonne réputation
elle sera capable de repartir la machine
reste à voir de combien l'homme
d'affaires devra réduire son prix pour
enfin passer à autre chose
ici marie claude morin radio canada
montréal
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d